you
the in-store era of professing Tierra
historian of sveti sweet spices
economist Nathan Scott till Alfred
novellas me man it is a great honor to
introduce the laureate of the
six-month Prize in Economic Sciences in
memory of Alfred Nobel professor Eugene
fama
thank you yo Majesties your Royal
Highnesses your excellencies honoured
laureates ladies and gentlemen I was
tempted to start with a story about what
happened to me but last time I gave a
talk in front of 1200 people but I
decided it was a little too racy and
I'll skip it let me begin by thanking
the economics committee for granting
this year's Prize in Economic Sciences
to me my colleague last Peter Hanson and
Robert Shiller I have learned much over
the years from ours as work and from
listening to his penetrating comments in
the work of others in the University of
Chicago as many research workshops I've
also learned a great deal from Bob's
writings and from his presentations at
Chicago over the years Barbara and I
agree on many things in finance we
disagree on others but always cordially
and with an eye toward learning more
from somebody with us with a different
viewpoint important to me personally as
a recognition the prize gives to the
standing of Finance in economics when I
started in the early 1960s finance is a
serious research area was just getting
started
we had Harry Markowitz is magnificent
Chicago PhD thesis on portfolio theory
and we had the theorems of Merton Miller
and Franco Modigliani on the irrelevance
of the financing decisions of firms
spurred by the coming of computers
empirical research and what became the
theory of efficient markets was getting
underway that was it in terms of major
paradigms there were no good research
journals in finance and almost all the
serious action in finance was at two
places Chicago and MIT researching
finance exploded over the next 20 years
William sharp joined Lintner
Robert Merton Robert Lucas that was
breeding and others developed a major
asset pricing models prescriptions about
how risks should be measured in the
relation between risk and expected
return Fischer black Myron Scholes and
Robert Merton developed the first
rigorous options pricing model equally
important to me anyway and an irony of
excellent young empirical researches
Lars and Barbara among the bed
into finance and all the major
theoretical paradigms were put through
the empirical wringer many times today a
research in finance continues its
impressive growth most major
universities now have first-rate
research faculties in finance they're at
now at least five excellent research
journals in finance and there are others
that have better than anything we had in
the 60s the major paradigms of finance
are familiar to PhD students in other
areas of economics and due to work of
people like Lars and Barb finance now
has a major role in macroeconomics in my
view after 50-plus years of vertiginous
growth finance is now comfortably first
among the areas of economics in which
there is a rich interplay between theory
empirical tests and the development of
models to accommodate the challenges
raised by evidence in the applied domain
transit finance is by far and away the
most successful area of economics in
terms of penetration of theory and
evidence into real world applications
the expense you know the finance
industry over the last 50 years
parallels the development of academic
research in finance and has borrowed
heavily from it researching finance has
been and continues to be a great ride it
has been incredibly satisfying to
participate in the growth of finance and
to know and learn from all the old
Giants who created the field and the new
giants like Lars and Bob who continued
to push its boundaries thank you